alors c'est pas du tout la chronique
innovations on est toujours dans la page
de sport nous sommes toujours le 2
octobre sur tv fil pour l'édition du 7 8
on parle de sport avec anthony et la
suite c'est avec de la course à pied et
nous avons de grands sportifs alaoui
inalco grand sportif
une invitée oui exactement un peu
inattendu 1 ce week-end il y avait le
35e paris-versailles donc cette grande
classique et une journaliste de tv fils
est un peu le frédéric de la nouvelle de
bfm tv
c'est alice gastines conçoit réalise
qu'on avait reçu d'ailleurs qu'à des
yvelines qu'on avait reçues sur ce
plateau effectivement lui aussi un jour
na'vi tuer des grand raid est habitué
des grands patrons n'avaient pas encore
faire un grand raid mais vous avez
participé à wil et d'édition vous êtes
accompagné de monsieur buissière
organisateur dû parcourir montigny c'est
ça voilà la traditionnelle course qui
qui va avoir lieu dimanche
l'événement de montigny au mois
d'octobre on en parle dans un instant
alors cette 35e édition du paris
versailles édition relever ou pas
édition plutôt relevé puisque le
vainqueur est arrivé en quelques 47
minutes à une moyenne de 18 presque 20
20 à l'heure le kenyan à woods était
balle ou un peu plus loin derrière en
1h43 mais une belle heure 43 et il y
avait notre consoeur avis c'était votre
première course à pied sur sur longue
distance
est ce que vous avez le sentiment
d'avoir fait une bonne course ah oui oui
pour moi j'ai fait une bonne course
parce que c'était ma première course
longue je m'étais entraîné mais pas pas
plus que ça ça faisait deux mois que je
courais régulièrement j'avais jamais
fait un 16 km on m'avait parlé de la
côte des gars comme comme quelque chose
d'insurmontable et puis finalement ça
s'est bien passé
donc oui si belle course c'est difficile
au milieu de 25 mille heures vous êtes
seulement 565 ça motive au contraire
est-ce que sayid un petit peu alors au
début c'est pas très motivant parce que
tout le monde va vite c'est sur les
quais en fait ça commence sur les quais
dont tout le monde de fond c'est payant
si ben en fait il faut garder son rythme
ne faut pas faut pas se laisser en fait
entraîner un parent par tout le monde et
puis finalement c'est motivant dans les
montées quand on double des gens
comme ça mais celle là elle est unique
et alors vous quand on était venus vous
suivre donc dimanche qu'on entend dans
cette course
vous m'avez parlé d'une ambiance très
particulière au départ ah oui au départ
donc on attend environ une bonne
demi-heure dans le sas de départ en fait
et puis donc on a froid dont moi j'avais
un sac poubelle sur moi pour rester au
chaud à l'intérieur et autour de moi
beaucoup d'hommes puis on était environ
20% de femmes à courir et en fait donc
les hommes jeter leurs pulls leur veste
c'est la braderie gratuite exactement il
y avait énormément de gens en fait aux
abords du sas de départ qui ramassait
les habits assez étonnant et alors au
cours de ces seize kilomètres le plus
dur c'est quoi ces deux ne peut-être pas
de sur jouer en fait comme on dit
souvent au foot ou dans notre sport ne
pas courir trop vite au dessus de 7 ans
de passage c'est ça exactement ce qui
est bien c'est que chaque kilomètre est
indiquée donc voilà on peut vite voir un
petit peu quelqu'un dans son vin ne pas
se laisser entraîner par les autres
comme je le disais et puis et puis
s'écouter